i'm so sorry
that we have to change our tour plans
for europe one more time but all i can
say is that
i'm doing my very best to get back to
the level that i need to be
so that i can give
a hundred percent at my shows
because that's what you deserve
celine dion emotionally tells her fans
she's cancelling the european leg of her
courage world tour once again just
telling you how i feel
and i wanted you to know
that i'm sorry for this news
i know you've all waited so long for the
concerts and i appreciate your loyalty
by now i am convinced
that you should be so fed up with all
this
and waiting for so long the singer
reveals the postponement is due to her
ongoing health issues the good news is
that i'm
doing a little bit better
but it's going very slow
and it's very frustrating for me you
know i'm getting treatment
from my doctors taking
medication
but i'm still experiencing some spasm
and it's taking a lot longer for me
to recover
than i had hoped i need to be in top
shape when i'm on stage
i honestly
can't wait
but um
i'm just not there yet it's very hard
for me not to perform because i love
this thing this isn't the first time the
grammy winner has put music on the back
burner to focus on her recovery in
january celine canceled her remaining
north american tour dates the shows she
previously postponed due to the pandemic
and in october another round of
cancellations this time for her las
vegas residency you can take so much
pressure you can take so much
strength and weight on your shoulder
sometimes it sometimes you cannot
control everything however through all
these unexpected changes celine
appreciates the love from her fans and
thank you so much for the messages of
love and support that you always sent to
my social media
means a lot to me i will always be very
thankful to my fans that
beyond the songs that i sing with them
beyond the support they give me
without so much explanation they
understood and while we're all ready for
the music icon to make her singing
comeback celine will be showcasing her
talent in another light with acting i
was born ready yep she will be making
her big screen debut alongside sam
hewitt and priyanka chopra jonas in the
film it's all coming back to me next
year
[Music]
and during sam's appearance on watch
what happens live last month he couldn't
help but gush about working with her
that was her acting debut right now what
an icon right like she's she's
incredible but she's not only
in the movie and she's really good and
she's extremely funny but she's also
supplying the music for the movie wow
written a song especially for us i can't
wait for you guys to see it
[Music]
you